nel 2002
Dopo anni di studio e di lavoro passati
fuori dalla fuori dalla Puglia
ho deciso di tornare nella nella mia
città per fare la professione di grafico
un anno dopo nasce questo studio che si
chiama uso opposto e grazie
e nasce a Grottaglie appunto la mia
città che diciamo questo particolare non
è trascurabile lo vedremo in seguito il
la geografia in cui ci ritroviamo è un
particolare che ritornerà poi nel nostro
discorso
abbiamo deciso di tornare a Grottaglie e
fare grafica e la grafica è una
disciplina che
si occupa di tradurre
in forma in forma visiva un concetto e
il concetto che si intende che si
intende comunicare Ciò avviene
attraverso l'utilizzo di immagini segni
Ma anche artefatti
una prova della sua assistenza ce
l'abbiamo della sua esistenza ce
l'abbiamo giornalmente perché in maniera
quasi subdola riesce ad entrare nelle
nostre case sotto forma di pubblicità di
stampa di di tv no
Diciamo che Ecco noi ci occupiamo di
comunicare qualcosa in effetti
che da che da valore a un prodotto
oppure descrive la qualità di un'azienda
oppure tante volte invece ci descrive
descriviamo in maniera
diciamo le bellezze di un luogo
turistico
come è facile dedurre una professione
che evidentemente sfrutta le qualità
innate Magari o acquisire nel tempo di
un grafico
per comunicare invece
per essere al servizio di altre persone
di esigenze altrui
a volte capita
che per ovviare a tutto questo Cioè al
peso evidentemente che è dai vincoli
produttivi e commerciali che che si
hanno in questa professione
di
un attimo fermarsi e voler fare qualcosa
per se stessi
in questo modo la grafica riesce anche a
creare delle storie ogni tanto
noi l'abbiamo fatto noi parlo di gente
che lavora adesso nel mio studio altri
visionari come me che hanno deciso di
lavorare qui al Sud
Nel nostro caso nel nostro studio
Pierfrancesco e Dario e abbiamo dato
vita a un progetto un progetto che si
chiama la Puglia la Puglia in un piatto
è un libro
che intende in qualche maniera
riuscire a creare un ponte tra quello
che facciamo
Normalmente cioè la grafica e gli input
che ci vengono trasferiti quasi
naturalmente dal territorio in cui
viviamo
col tempo ci siamo resi conto in realtà
che molto del materiale produttivo che
veniva fuori dal nostro studio aveva le
sembianze vere e proprie di diciamo
elementi che appartenevano al nostro al
nostro territorio
e quindi ci siamo detti perché non
parlare evidentemente di
ciò che
il nostro territorio offre in termini di
eccellenza e descriverlo Però in maniera
in maniera diversa del tutto del tutto
diversa vista dagli occhi dei dei
grafici
in un certo senso facciamo un'operazione
filologica Cioè nel senso intendiamo
illustrare
dare lustro alle nostre eccellenze a
quello che il nostro territorio può
offrire e lo facciamo e questo per
questo Ritorniamo al fattore geografico
su un piatto che il piatto di ceramica e
il piatto di ceramica tradizionale
diciamo di Grottaglie del paese dal
quale dal quale proveniamo
per fare questo
diamo inizio una ricerca
una ricerca che facciamo sul campo
in un certo senso
Entriamo
nel mondo
diciamo produttivo anche della cultura
della cultura locale e facciamo sì che
la grafica diventi un elemento
pedagogico cioè aiuti a decodificare i
segni di un territorio e in un certo
senso a renderceli più più vicini
in questo caso noi siamo andati
nelle zone dedicate appunto alla cultura
Popolare siamo entrati nei mercati siamo
andati nelle pescherie
tutti quei luoghi che se siete pugliesi
vi saranno sicuramente familiari
abbiamo detto che Abbiamo trasportato e
trasferito le immagini della nostra
cultura
sui nostri sui nostri piatti per farlo
abbiamo utilizzato un mirino abbiamo
preso un pezzo di cartone ce ne siamo
andati in giro per la Valle d'Itria per
quegli scenari bellissimi della nostra
Puglia e abbiamo inquadrato manualmente
ciò che ci veniva in mente ciò che
avremmo voluto
rappresentare su sui nostri sui nostri
piatti
si è trattato in realtà di descrivere su
in questo libro dei valori
di riportarli alla luce
i valori appunto tradizionali del nostro
territorio quelli che abbiamo assorbito
nel corso degli anni l'abbiamo fatto in
maniera diversa abbiamo voluto
reinterpretare le ricette
quello che è noto come essere uno dei
piatti diciamo più apprezzati della
cucina pugliese cioè le polpette noi le
abbiamo viste così
in un certo senso è la versione
dialettale di un piatto Come quella
delle polpette perché in un certo senso
ci porta
da quando eravamo bambini a indicare
a utilizzare il termine polpette per
indicare che ne so i gol no
un 5 a 0 per noi sono cinque polpette a
zero
oppure abbiamo preso come riferimento
degli elementi
diciamo
caratteristici sempre del nostro
territorio dal punto di vista
appunto dei mezzi ciò che in altre parti
d'Italia è soltanto un semplice mezzo di
trasporto da noi invece diventa un
negozio a cielo aperto
ed è facile trovarlo nei punti di uscita
delle città
è facile capire intuire che se si tratta
di cozze il fatto di essere ai limiti
della città porta sicuramente dei
vantaggi almeno alla popolazione
oppure abbiamo tirato fuori quei valori
fondamentali che adesso è difficile
ritrovare come è scampagnate fuori porta
No quelle che negli anni 70 o 80 ancora
dalle nostre parti erano ben presenti le
famiglie che si riunivano andavano fuori
e portavano con sé il cibo che diventava
cibo da trasporto oppure prende la come
riferimento
Diciamo la natura lo vediamo in queste
forme delle nostre classiche scarcelle
un elemento tipico della cucina della
cucina pugliese
oppure un altro elemento che ci veniva
in mente quello che noi pugliesi
riusciamo a fare benissimo cioè riuscire
a dare
diciamo di un mezzo riuscire a fare di
un mezzo
un utilizzo del tutto diverso
per cui da uno stendipanni si arriva
invece a
ad avere un oggetto che serve per fare
essiccare il pesce
Chi di voi o di noi
ricorderà le texture presente sui
presenti sulle sugli abiti delle donne
le donne del Sud quelli classici e che
avevano appunto queste particolari
decorazioni che a noi hanno ricordato
molto invece le forme
Che poi abbiamo inteso di produrre
relative al riso oppure alle cozze e ci
venivano in mente queste donne che ecco
perché il punto interrogativo al posto
della testa è una domanda che ci siamo
fatti da noi del perché appunto queste
donne in piena estate vestivano sempre
di nero e qualcosa che insomma rimane
della nostra tradizione
oppure chi come me appartiene agli anni
avrà sicuramente notato ho giocato nel
corso degli anni con diciamo con quei
giochi che
quei famosi giochi degli anni 80 Le
Antiche console in cui a farla da
padrone era un grosso granchio pixellato
che tentava di invadere di invadere la
terra
quando invece noi vedevamo tutt'altro
vedevamo e sentivamo i profumi
dei granchi
che assaggiavamo che assaggiavamo a
pranzo o a cena uno di quei Sapori
talmente forti che è difficile
dimenticare
e noi l'abbiamo interpretato in questo
modo
Per non parlare poi di elementi della
tradizione che si sono quasi
definitivamente persi e che abbiamo
avuto recuperare
come la presenza delle donne fuori fuori
dalle case e ci veniva in mente sempre
questo oggetto cioè questa sedia di
paglia che messa fuori
dalle case
risultava un po' come diciamo una sedia
che occupasse il territorio
nelle ore più calde della giornata
perché poi di sera invece si
faceva questo rito che era il rito della
musicata la chiamiamo noi no cioè
di riuscire a con un attraverso un masso
levigato a sbucciare le fave secche
è una cosa che non si fa più quindi
l'abbiamo interpretata Quasi come
l'anima
di questa fava di questo particolare
rito che non c'è più e che è che va via
e in un altro modo invece abbiamo voluto
interpretare un'altra ricetta della
tradizione del famoso polpo polpo
affogato e ci è venuto in mente Invece
la generosità di noi pugliesi No quella
tanto decantata e ad un certo punto ci
ha fatto talmente pena che è uno
scafandro per farlo respirare ci stava
bene
ora in questo modo sono state
realizzate circa 60 ricette della
tradizione
pugliese 60 ricette che sono state
realizzate all'interno delle nostre case
sono state poi fotografate e poi
debitamente mangiate e quasi a in un
certo senso
rappresentare un rito ancestrale no come
come succede nei popoli primitivi in cui
mangiare qualcosa di forte Ti fa ti
rafforza ancora di più
qua lo potete vedere benissimo
succede che questo libro finalmente
Trova
trova la fine perché è durato veramente
molto
trovo la fine però a un certo punto ci
chiediamo se è il caso di
portarlo in giro ad editori a
presentarlo a presso degli editori o
comunque dei produttori per capirne la
bontà Cioè se il caso effettivamente di
riuscire di riuscire a metterlo sul
mercato ci viene detto che un libro
difficilmente piazzabile come dicevano
loro dal momento che risulta essere un
ibrido non è né un libro di cucina
quindi un vero e proprio ricettario Come
si usa ultimamente presentare in tv e
neanche un libro un libro di design per
cui decidiamo un certo punto di
tagliare la testa al toro e
utilizzare quello che lo strumento che
negli ultimi anni può darci Ecco
la certezza un po' di
quell'uso Democratico che si può che si
può fare di internet e decidiamo di
lanciare un nostro sito un sito dedicato
al libro
e
in un certo senso poi dopo
chiamare in causa alcuni blogger
internazionali a cui farlo a cui far
recensire il libro o comunque
diciamo pensare di capire cosa ne cosa
ne pensano
E siamo nel settembre del 2010
noi lanciamo questo sito Abbiamo appena
un paio di visite
due mesi dopo Grazie appunto ad alcune
recensioni fatte diciamo da blogger
internazionali più che italiani
il sito viene visitato in da 9 Paesi da
53 città e da ben tre continenti
dopo tre mesi diciamo i dati subiscono
anche un ulteriore impennata fino ad
arrivare ai giorni nostri ad agosto in
cui
con soddisfazione possiamo dire che è un
prodotto partito dalle nostre case
che in un certo senso ha voluto mettere
in luce le eccellenze della Puglia
è stato visitato da ben 90 paesi
eccetera eccetera di città e cinque
continenti
Come spesso accade Ecco il rumore
provocato all'esterno svegliati in casa
in questo caso
sveglia i media diciamo locali almeno
non dico nazionali dal momento che è
il marzo 2012 quando questo libro
a questo libro viene assegnato il
secondo premio A livello mondiale e in
una manifestazione che si chiama gourman
World
e che viene realizzato viene realizzato
a Parigi e premia diciamo i migliori
titoli editoriali riguardo alla
Gastronomia
Insomma devo dire che a
bocce ferme è veramente
difficile pensare che partendo
evidentemente da
veramente pochissimi dati che avevamo in
mano si sia riusciti poi a
ad essere catapultati all'interno di una
realtà come ad esempio il teatro delle
folibergé del quale avevamo soltanto
sentito parlare
sui libri Ecco
sapevamo delle gesta che avevano
compiuto all'interno di questo teatro e
riuscire
e riuscire appunto a ad entrare in
questo in questa in questa atmosfera
di globalità cioè la Puglia che incontra
il resto del mondo e ci si scambia in
una
Diciamo in una in un contesto così così
importante delle informazioni
tutto questo potrebbe sembrare la storia
Scusate la storia
autocelebrativa di uno studio in realtà
non è così in realtà volevamo mettere in
rilievo ciò che la Puglia ci può dare
con le sue eccellenze parliamo sempre di
un di un territorio arido no
dove bisogna da dove bisogna andare via
per trovare occasioni in questo caso
ci ha dato l'occasione di
Ecco di parlare con un linguaggio della
Puglia
in qualche modo è voluto
che attiene alla modernità della nostra
professione
e che in un certo senso ha fatto sì che
fossimo orgogliosi di appartenere di
appartenere a questa terra
adesso non di rado qualcuno mi chiede
ancora come mai facciamo questo lavoro
qui e non da qualche altra parte dove
Evidentemente gli aspetti economici gli
stimoli sono sono molto più importanti
E allora mi piace dire che
lavorare qui è in qualche modo come
avere a disposizione un foglio bianco
sul quale disegnare invece che uno
spartito dove diciamo i segni e la
musica è già scritta Grazie